if you look at the object detection
literature there's a set of ideas called
region proposals that's been very
influential in computer vision as well I
wanted to make this video optional
because I tend to use the region
proposal set of algorithms a bit less
often but nonetheless it has been an
influential body of work and an idea
that you might come across in your own
work let's take a look so if you recall
the sliding windows idea and you would
take a trained classifier and run it
across all of these different windows
and run a detector to see if there's a
car a pedestrian or maybe a motorcycle
now you couldn't run the algorithm
convolutional lead but one downside that
the algorithm is it just classifies a
lot of regions where there's clearly no
object right so this rectangle down here
is pretty much blank it's clearly
nothing interesting there to classify
and maybe it was also running it on this
rectangle which you know looks like
there's nothing that interesting there
so what rosco straight Jeff Dunn who
travelled arrow and Jitendra Malik
proposed in a paper sight to the bottom
of the slide is an algorithm called our
CNN which stands for regions with
convolutional networks or regions with
CNN's and what that does is it tries to
pick just a few regions that make sense
to run your confident classifier on so
rather than running your sliding windows
on every single window you instead
select just a few windows and run you're
confident classifier on just a few
windows the way that they perform the
region proposals is to run an algorithm
called a segmentation algorithm that
results in this output on the right in
order to figure out what could be
objects so for example the segmentation
algorithm finds a blob over here and so
you might pick that bounding box and say
let's run the classifier on that block
looks like is this little green thing
that finds a blob there and soon I'll
also run a crossfire on that rectangle
to see if there's anything interesting
there and in this case this blue blob if
it runs the classifier on that hopefully
you find a pedestrian and if you run it
on this light cyan
maybe you'll find a car maybe not
Marshall so the details of this this is
called a segmentation algorithm and what
you do is you find maybe two thousand
blobs and place bounding boxes around
about two thousand blobs and run your
classifier on just those two thousand
blobs which and this can be a much
smaller number of positions on which to
run you're confident classifier then if
you have to run it at every single
position throughout the image and this
is a special case if you are running
you're confident not just on square
shape regions we're running them on tall
skinny regions to try to find
pedestrians we're running them on you
know why fat regions try to find cars
and running them at multiple scales as
well so that's the are CNN or the region
with CNN a region of CNN features idea
now it turns out the our CNN Avram is
still quite slow so there's been a line
of work to explore how to speed up this
algorithm so the basic our CNN algorithm
would propose regions using some
algorithm and then classify the Patrol's
regions one at a time and for each of
the regions it will output the label so
they're a car is there a pedestrian is
there a motorcycle there and also output
a bounding box so you can get an
accurate bounding box if indeed there is
a object in that region so just to be
clear the our CNN algorithm doesn't just
trust the bounding box it was given it
also outputs a bounding box B xB YB hbw
in order to get a more accurate bounding
box than whatever happened to surround
the block that the image segmentation
algorithm gave it so it can get pretty
accurate bounding boxes now one downside
of the our CNN algorithm was that is
actually quite slow so over the years
they've been a few improvements to the
our CNN algorithm Roscoe Shrek proposed
the fast our CNN algorithm and it's
basically the our CNN algorithm but with
a convolutional implementation of
sliding windows so the original
implantation would actually classify the
regions one at a time so fast our CNN
news
a convolutional implementation of
sliding windows and this is roughly
similar to the idea you saw in the
fourth video of this week and that
speeds up our CNN quite a bit it turns
out that one of the problems with false
Austrian an algorithm is that the
clustering step to propose the regions
is still quite slow and so a different
group shouting rent timing her Roscoe
shriek and teen son proposed the faster
our CN n algorithm which uses a
convolutional neural network instead of
one of the more traditional segmentation
algorithms to propose the blobs of the
rows to regions and that wound up
running quite a bit faster than the fast
our CN n algorithm although I think the
faster our CN n algorithm most
implementations are usually still quite
a bit slower than the yellow algorithm
so the idea of median proposals has been
quite influential in computer vision and
I want you to know about these ideas
because you see others still use these
ideas for myself and this is my personal
opinion not the opinion of the computer
vision research community as a whole I
think that we can proposal is an
interesting idea but that not having two
steps first proposed regions and then
classify it being able to do you know
everything more or at the same time
similar to the Yola order you only look
ones algorithm that seems to me like a
more promising direction for the long
term but that's my personal opinion and
not necessary the opinion of the whole
computer vision research community so
feel free to take that with a grain of
salt but I think that the RC n an idea
you might come up you might come across
others using it so it's well worth
knowing as well so you can understand
others algorithms better so that we've
now finished up our material for this
week on object detection I hope you
enjoy working on this week's program
exercise and either forward to seeing
you next week